all right so we left off with the Battle
of Gettysburg from July 1st to 3rd 1863
and as I mentioned in the last video
Gettysburg was a really significant
battle in the Civil War it was a real
turning point for the Civil War at which
we brought the forces of the south up
into the north for a second attempt at
an invasion and once again was turned
away by the forces of Union General
George Meade Gettysburg was the most
destructive battle of the Civil War
there were about 50,000 casualties and
it along with the victory at the siege
of Vicksburg which followed the day
after on July 4th really start to
signify the beginning of the end of the
Confederacy's bid for independence now
what you may not know about the Battle
of Gettysburg is that it was almost the
end of the war in fact Lee took his army
trying to cross back over the Potomac
into the south and the Potomac was
flooded so he and his army were pretty
much pinned between this flooded river
and the forces of Meade in the north now
Meade if he had attacked probably could
have won the war right there and then
and Lincoln was so angry that Meade
didn't attack he wrote this him this
really nasty letter saying I think you
don't even realize what you've done here
by letting Lee get away we could have
ended the war right now but actually
Lincoln didn't send that letter he
thought better of it and instead
congratulated me Don his great victory
and the boost of morale that it gave the
forces of the United States at
Gettysburg so now I'd like to take some
time to talk about the Gettysburg
Address which is arguably the most
famous speech in American history it's
pretty up there and it's extremely short
it's only 272 words now Lincoln
delivered the Gettysburg Address on
November 19th 1863 so it's about three
and a half months after the Battle of
Gettysburg
I think the Gettysburg Address is really
interesting and all of the events
surrounding it the circumstances
surrounding it
tell us a lot about the culture and
society of the 19th century the progress
of the civil war and also the way that
things are going to kind of be wrapped
up in the end of the Civil War what the
ultimate message of the war is going to
be and what the blueprint of reuniting
the country is going to look like so
Gettysburg was this tremendously
destructive battle with 50 thousand
casualties and remember that after the
battle Lee is kind of fleeing for the
life of his army and not too long after
that Meade pursues him so the armies
make kind of an incredible mess and then
they take off leaving this tiny town of
Gettysburg which has I think about 2,500
people to deal with 50,000 casualties so
men who are dead or wounded may be
missing in action somewhere and they
really just don't have the capacity for
it so the governor of Pennsylvania
contracts out to create a cemetery and
in this period of three and a half
months there are bodies literally
rotting on the ground so it's a bit of a
hellscape the entire town of Gettysburg
stinks they had to burn all the dead
horses so it smells like burning horses
and rotting human flesh it is not a
happy place to be so the town of
Gettysburg and the state of Pennsylvania
are very eager to get a cemetery
underway at Gettysburg and so they begin
the process of burying the bodies and
reburying the bodies trying to identify
the various corpses that are left on the
field and they ask this man Edward
Everett who was really the preeminent
orator of his day he was like the rock
concert of the 19th century to come and
give an oration on the dedication of the
Gettysburg Cemetery and they say Everett
do you think you could do this on
October 23rd and Everett says no I
definitely won't be ready to have a
script for an oration by then so can you
push it back too
November 19th so it's actually Everett
who decides what day the Gettysburg
Address is going to take place on
Lincoln by contrast was only invited
maybe a month or so before and he wasn't
really considered the important speaker
of the day that was Everett but Lincoln
knew that he wanted to make something of
his remarks at Gettysburg now remember
that an election year is coming up in
1864 it's been a hard year Gettysburg is
the first major victory that the United
States forces have had in a long time so
he kind of wants to make sure that he
can set the tone of how Gettysburg is
going to be remembered and to reconfirm
a sense of mission about the Civil War
right when there's been such a great
loss of life and when you're standing
around looking at that loss of life it
can be very easy to get discouraged and
say okay maybe we should just end the
war we should have peace now allow the
south to secede and retain slavery and
Lincoln wants to make sure that people
come away from this dedication at
Gettysburg with a renewed sense of
purpose in continuing to fight the Civil
War now there's a common misconception
that Lincoln wrote the Gettysburg
Address on the back of an envelope on
the train to Gettysburg that is almost
certainly not the case because Lincoln
was a planner remember that he was self
educated and he always took a lot of
time in anything that he wrote he wrote
drafts and got revisions and wrote yet
another draft he liked to be extremely
precise with his language and you can
see that throughout pretty much
everything that he's written that he is
an extremely effective and eloquent
writer and that wasn't just because he
was an extremely eloquent person he was
that's because he worked really hard at
it so we're fairly certain that Lincoln
spent some time drafting the Gettysburg
Address in the White House long before
he left so the day arrives November 19th
1863 and Everett gets set up in a tent
because he's the real
headliner of the day now Edward Everett
was I think the undisputed champion of
giving speeches in his day he was an
incredible speaker and everyone who was
there actually agreed that Everett did
an incredible job speaking he spoke for
over two hours
and if that sounds like a really long
time to us for the 19th century that was
actually pretty appropriate that's what
people expected out of oratory in the
19th century they paid attention
they were riveted by it it was like
going to see a movie or a concert today
so people really wanted to hear Everett
talk for that long in fact they were
quite confused when Lincoln didn't talk
for a longer than just a couple of
minutes a lot of people even were
reported to say was that it so here in
the center we have a picture of the day
at Gettysburg and we're pretty sure that
this is the only confirmed picture of
Lincoln at Gettysburg now he's kind of
small here but I think this is a really
interesting picture because it gives you
a sense of what Lincoln's stature was at
the time and also the people that he
surrounded himself with so this is
Lincoln here right here in the center
not wearing a hat looking down and then
he's surrounded by the important people
of his cabinet so right here pretty sure
this is William Seward who was the
Secretary of State and over here these
are John Hay and John Nicolay who were
Lincoln's personal secretaries they went
everywhere with him and this guy up here
is a little harder to see that is Edward
Everett now imagine what it would have
been like to stand on this field in this
growing cemetery at Gettysburg and
listen to Edward Everett and Abraham
Lincoln talk about the meaning of the
battle around you now remember that it's
November so it's been three and a half
months since the battle but the Battle
of Gettysburg took place in the
beginning of July and it was 90 hundred
degrees outside so when Lee and Meade
left Gettysburg they left 8,000 or more
bodies
rotting in the hot July Sun and many of
them had been out there rotting for
those three months so when you were
standing on this field at Gettysburg
there would have literally been human
bones around you that you could see it
probably would have still smelled pretty
terrible so you're really kind of in the
thick of the destruction of the Civil
War and listening to these two men who
are trying to make meaning out of it for
you
so Everett gets up and he gives this
fiery speech for two hours and he goes
through all of the details of the battle
and says this is what happened over on
that hill and this is what happened over
on that hill and he tries to rev up the
crowd into kind of this patriotic fervor
of not only appreciating the glory of
the Union victory at Gettysburg but also
renewing their hatred for their enemy
and then Lincoln gets up to speak and he
speaks for just a couple minutes and
we'll talk more about that in the next
video